meantime an event aimed at educating
drivers about safety near cyclists is
happening right now in the west valley
local law enforcement agencies are
taking part in this it comes after that
crash that killed five cyclists on the
95 near searchlight that we were just
telling you about
hector mejia live in the far west valley
with the details hi hector
hey there well police are stopping
drivers who do not give up an entire
lane when it's safe to do so and joining
us this afternoon we have keeley brooks
with the
southern nevada bicycle coalition to
explain the efforts underway
until 3 pm how's it going hi hector
yeah today we're having this law
enforcement event to educate motorists
about the three-foot
move-over law which is is
really just to have motorists become
aware of other users of the roadway like
cyclists on the side of the road
and we the law states that you should
move over an entire lane if you're going
to pass
a cyclist keeley what's the main message
we talk about
issuing tickets we talk about the law
but seems like drivers
seem to ignore the traffic laws quite
often what's the main message this
afternoon
the main message is to to pause for a
minute if you're driving
and recognize there's other people on
the road and just to
to take a breath and and wait and
that can save a life and uh do you know
firsthand how tragic things can turn
you knew several people who were hurt
and killed
on december 10th tragically
that was a day that i hope never happens
again
just uh yeah hearing that friends of
mine
will not be with us again i'll never be
able to ride with them again i'll never
be able to trail run with them again and
that their families
won't have them there for christmas and
new year's is just heartbreaking
and so today's event is really is really
meant to
make sure that motorists and all users
of the roadway
uh notice cyclists on the side of the
road notice that we're there
recognize that we need to give them
space so you don't take somebody's loved
ones
from them kaylee thank you for talking
to us even during hard times and
opening up and sharing your story with
us thank you reporting
in the far west valley hector mejia
eight news